اقل الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد رئيسه
الحكومه نجلاء مدن وعين احمد الحشاني خلفا
لها في اول خطوه من نوعها بعد اعتماد
النظام الرئاسي في تونس كان ذلك خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات بل
اليات التي اتخذها سعيد للتوصل الى قرار
اقاله رئيسه الحكومه ما المعايير التي
اختار سعيد على اساسها رئيس الحكومه
الجديد وكيف يمكن مقارنه اداء واليات
تعيين حكومات حقبه سعيد
بسابقاتها من حكومات ما بعد الثوره
انا اؤكد لك مئه بالمئه ان الرئيس اختار
من قرارات نفسه باعتبار انه اختاره تكنو
هذا الرجل مدير عام سابق للشؤون القانونيه
والتسريحه بالبنك المركزي ويعرف خفايا
الفساد متطلبات المرحله الجديده وصعوبه
المرحله الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه التي تمر
بها الدوله منذ تقريبا
سنوات منذ سنه 2018 تقريبا عقب تحصلنا على
عده قروض بالاف المليارات
ذهبت هذا المنثوره ولم تحصل منها الدوله
على شيء وبقيت خزائن دوله فارغه تقريبا ثم
عجز ميزان تجاري 42 الف مليار ثم اصبحنا
غير قادرين حتى على السداد فهنا وجد نفسه
الرئيس امام مرحله جديده يعرفها هو فقط
نعلم لماذا عينت بوتين حتى نتفاجا لماذا
اقيلت وما سر على يسري على سيد الحشاني هي
تعيينات منتصف الليل حيث الناس نيام
ويعامل المواطنين سهام معامله الرعايه لا
معامله المواطنين حتى المعلومه لم ترد
كامله فالتحديات الاقتصاديه تتطلب ان
يتصدى لها شخص ذو خلفيه اقتصاديه والحال
ان خلفيه السيد الحشاني وهو غير معروف لا
داخل البلاد ولا خارجان هي خلفيه قانونيه
لم يتحمل اي مسؤوليه اداله او التسيير في
حياته الرئيس شكري حتى عندما عين هشام
المشيشي وبودنه في المرحله الفارطه اختار
التكنوترات بانه يريد ان ينتقل بتونس من
تلك المرحله الاولى التي هي في عمق زجاجه
والتي يصطدم فيها باحزاب معارضه وضعيات
سياسيه حرجه جدا الى مرحله ثانيه ونراها
في خطابي اليوم عندما قال ليس النظام الذي
احكمه الان هو الفاسد الفاسده هي المظلوم
ويجب اصلاحه ويتصرف
بالتصرف المالكي في ملكه ولا يسال عما
يفعل
من الخفايا لا يعلم ان الرئيس المعايير لا
يعلمها الا رئيس والمواطنون
يتبع بشيء في بلغات من اصل قليله من رئاسه
الجمهوريه ليس صحيح باعتبار رئيس يقوم
بتعينات
على ذلك
فليشرح هو يقول لنا الرئيس اختار الرئيس
الحكومه رئاسي الان لا يعجبها رئاسي
المسؤوليه واضح المسؤوليه يتحملها الان
يتحملها رئيس الحكومه اذا كان هناك فشل او
هناك او نقص على مستوى
المناخ الاقتصادي او ضعف على مستوى
النتائج لان السياسه نتائج اقوال وافعال
وليست يعني الراس فلنخرج من هذا النقاش
البيزنطي الذي يوجههم عن القدماء
المسؤوليه تتحملها
وهذا امر غريب وعجيب هذه الحكومه ليس لاي
صلاحيات وليس لها اي سلطه كل السلطه
يتحمله كل الصلاحيات هي السيد رئيس
الجمهوريه هذا مكتوب في الدستور الذي كتبه
بنفسه لنفسه وهو يشرف على كل المجالات اذا
كانت السيده بوتين ناجحه فلماذا تم
استغناء عنها اما اذا كانت فاشله فمن
يجيبها فيما فشلت وهل تتحمل هي المسؤوليه
ام باقي اعضاء حكومه
رئيس لم يوجه لهم هذه المره الى المعارضه
الرئيس له وجه لهم في خطاب واضح الى
منظومه قديمه ان الرئيس تحدث بشكل متكرر
عن منظومه قديمه ويواجه كلامه الى رئيس
حكومه جديد يجب هذه المنظومه ان تمحى من
على وجه البسيطه لانها السبب في خراب تونس
وخاصه في الطابع المالي والطابع الاقتصادي
ليس هناك برنامج يمكن المحاسبه عليه هذا
شخص غير معلوم الماضي اذا لا يمكن التنبؤ
بالمستقبل تونس التي بدات الربيعابين
العربي
تستحق ان استشار شعبها وان تستشار نخبتها
تونس
بالكفاءات ولا يمكن ان يعين رئيس حكومتها
من خارج هذه الكفاءات وان يعقد المواطن
ايديهم وينتظروا ما تجود به الاقد